let's speak to dr. Bob Arnot he's a
medical doctor and also the former chief
medical correspondent at NBC News he
joins us now on skype from Vermont
doctor honored let me start with the
question that everyone is speculating
about when are we likely to have a
vaccine and enough of it produced to end
this pandemic it's quite the process it
really is you know right now they are
already scaling up the production of
some vaccines that they believe are
promising so that should these phase 1
phase 2 trials work there be a real
opportunity to to have a vaccine they've
said from the outset it's 12 to 18
months right now Nastasia I'm putting
most of my hope on current drugs for
instance NICU is now they're using these
il-6 r receptor blockers so it's a
mouthful there but this cytokine storm
it seems to kill so many people they
have a variety of different drugs
they're looking there remedy severe is
another one antiviral drug so I think
unfortunately these vaccines really are
a year to a year-and-a-half way unless
there's some kind of great miracle lots
of scale lots of only produce it but you
have to show it safe and you have to
show it's effective well let me ask you
then about safety I see Oxford
University is starting human trials of
their vaccine this week and I know
there's been speculation in the
scientific community about possible ways
to try to speed up testing but surely
there are ethical implications there
well you know we always say medicine
first do no harm and there have been
vaccines in the past that have done farm
that have caused infections you have two
different kinds you haven't Lee call a
live attenuated vaccine which means it's
actually the virus but it is not
supposed to cause a lot of illness that
caused a lot of concern back in the
polio era and then there's a matter of
taking you know particularly antigens
you know parts of the dangerous parts of
the virus and creating an antibody to it
now right now we have this technique we
take the antibodies from people who were
ill and transfuse those into people who
are currently ill so that's so that's
working almost like an active vaccine
but it's it's a ways off I would say
estas you know it's very interesting
with this w-h-o meeting today because
you know they fell on their face during
the Ebola epidemic that we
with you on al-jazeera in West Africa it
was a catastrophe and there's a lot of
blame more than enough to go around
certainly China has blamed for not
having inform the world early enough the
World Health Organization saying that it
wasn't transmitted person to person for
not encouraging flight bans earlier and
the United States you know we had months
to prepare for this and you know we're
still short of the right kinds of tests
and whatnot so I think unfortunately
some politics involved here and that the
president doesn't seem to like the World
Health Organization and they're they're
taking a fall for this but it would be a
great tragedy if the United States
didn't contribute money to the WHL
because the African elseís was so
fragile and the whu-oh supports so much
so that I would hate to see that we
really you know don't pay up over time
but let me assure you this though that I
think you know deborah birx I was part
of the White House team here is on the
phone daily with people all around the
world both in terms of helping countries
in Africa nation is example and in
trying to coordinate this effort our FDA
here and of course Tony Fauci are again
on daily phone calls with pharmaceutical
companies around the world so I would
just assure you that there really is
active coordination between the National
Institutes of Health the FDA and the
White House Task Force and drug and
vaccine developers all over the world
obviously selling that story tonight but
of course some bad blood here
unfortunately it's just the wrong time
between the US administration in the
World Health Organization well we are
seeing this unprecedented cooperation
within the scientific community in the
hunt for a vaccine but surely there's
also a bit of competition as to who
might find one first and I imagine that
would have implications for who actually
gets access to it before others so how
can poorer countries be sure that
they'll get the access they need when
they need it well understand see that's
the great tragedy here is I mean like
poor countries the first thing they're
gonna need are ventilators some
countries like Kenya might have four or
five ventilators I mean you need
ventilators you need protective gear all
of the things in the United States has
been scrambling to get and then China
began to scramble to get in early
January you know unfortunately going to
be tragically short and so much of
Africa
these medications and vaccines are
produced in mass quantities
you know usually the pharmaceutical
companies are pretty good about getting
them to those various countries but as
you point out there's a mad worldwide
competition now companies and
governments are sharing much more than
they than they used to or ordinarily
would but clearly a certain companies
would want to be the winner and they're
scrambling hard to get a vaccine when I
was little we had polio and you know one
morning you'd wake up and there'd be
somebody be playing ball within a
football field and then afternoon or
evening they'd be in an iron lung and we
waited with bated breath we're really
quite fearful for our lives for a
vaccine then and then when it came with
with Jonas Salk and with with Sabin of
course was like the greatest really if
the greatest miracle of all time so I
have great hopes but I really think that
the therapeutics will pay off first in
the vaccines probably are a whole year
away and still very limited resources
they're on both counts dr. Bob Collins a
medical doctor and former chief medical
correspondent for NBC News thanks for
joining us on al-jazeera